[Music]
good evening from Washington I'm Laura
Ingram thanks for joining us tonight in
the wake of Tuesday's terror attack in
New York City the issue of chain
migration is rapidly becoming one of the
biggest issues facing America the
process seems so kind and is often
framed as family oriented immigration
when one immigrant comes into the
country he or she later brings in his
family members but this process very
quickly increases the number of
immigrants living in the United States
get this a report from the Center for
Immigration Studies says that 61% of
immigrants admitted to the United States
in the last 35 years are here due to
chain migration 61% that's 20 million
people the issue has become even hotter
following our exclusive interview with
President Trump last night I asked him
whether any deal with Congress to allow
so-called dreamers to stay in the United
States legally whether it should address
the issue of chain migration you talked
about a verified building the wall chain
migration which is a huge all those
things are happening part of any daca
deal so if the Democrats want dreamer
help they're gonna have to do yeah we're
gonna have to do a verified chain
migration sure chain migration is one of
the most important things that most
people that are requirement for you till
yesterday most people never heard of
chain migration I gave a form of a press
conference and I started talking about
chain migration and this horrible animal
he's an animal as far as I'm concerned
23 people have touched him maybe came in
because he was in and he was only in
with a green card supposedly but chain
migration where his whole family comes
and his mother can come in his father
his grandmother everybody comes in chain
migration is a disaster for this country
and it's going to end now I've been
talking about it for a while but I think
the public until yesterday probably
never heard about chain right
Ekans didn't want to touch it for a long
time you have the picture - what the
Republicans want to touch it now it's
become a very very strong point right
well it'd be part of a dreamer deal deal
it'll be part of a dock a deal is a lot
different than dream I mean for the
deferred action for childhood arrivals
yeah will will you require that if any
amnesty talks will will will require
chain migration I don't think any
Republican would vote for anything
having to do with leaving chain
migration chain migration is a disaster
for this country joining us now for
reaction from Fort Worth Texas is
immigration attorney Francisco Aaron
ondas a dual citizen of Mexico and the
United States
Fernando grateful to you tell us why
tell us why chain migration is something
that should be continued even given the
numbers Fernando we're seeing 61 percent
of all new immigrants in the United
States comes from this process because
migration that's because there's no such
things chain migration it's called
family based immigration and that's the
only thing we have in the United States
there's two honors to this Maajid and
viola they will agree if we could just
remove the politics from immigration
it's just the law of supply and demand
if there are jobs they're going to come
there is no such thing as chain
migration nobody's ever heard of it
before they say well family based
petition okay well this is what it is
I'll explain it to you when an
individual comes into the United States
this is a fact this is you know
according to u.s. statistics though an
individual comes into the United States
and a green card
his family men don't come in with a
green card he become he becomes a
permanent legal resident of the United
States that ultimately get a green card
so when he comes into the same legal
residence sweetheart let me just finish
okay and then you can make your salient
point all right when he or she is
admitted into the United States you get
that permanent resident status as we saw
with the terrorists from Uzbekistan you
are then
to give preferential treatment to
certain family members this is a fact
now I know you'd like to call it family
base yes they are family members you're
absolutely right about that however this
sheer number of people results in a very
difficult thing for both number one
assimilation number two proper vetting
number three a strain on social services
in the United States no no strain on
social services because most of the
people coming in are lower skilled labor
who obviously are competing with lower
skilled American labor which is our
first responsibility it's just so wrong
that is just wrong miss Ingram you know
better you know better because because
there's only one degree of consequent II
it doesn't for a brother to bring a
brother he's like 18 years for it to
come it's not like a mass influx of
immigrants because chain migration if
there's no such thing as chain migrants
family-based petition and that is what
this country was built upon actually
actually actually the country was not
built upon family immigration into the
United States the country is founded on
will constitutional principles of
liberty and justice for all and that
means the Liberty do you believe from
Cisco you're a dual assistant by the way
if you had to choose right now which
country would you choose America baby
yeah I'm talking about get the dual
front seats go I don't get the whole
dual citizen thing I mean I guess I
guess maybe if someone offered me dual
citizenship might but I don't really
understand why my children have a
European Union citizenship that means
that immigrants could hire them yeah
three there you European Union City so
you go to work countries that you're
citizens
oh wow Dutch Mexican and United States
yes but would you do you think that
people have a little you know do you
think individuals have a universal right
to enter the United States from
anyways alright there's no rice there's
only opportunities this is the promised
land this is the land that people not
trying to get to it
people hang under a train for eight
hours trying to cross the motor to get
here anything that's right you think
they wanted an opportunity do you think
businesses that hire illegal labor in
the United States that pay them the
wages they pay them that are under
market wages do you think that's
compassionate it would ask for we need
immigration reform yes
look they're coming supplies jobs are
going to come you know it's not about
compassionate it's about who's gonna do
the job that they're gonna do now what
we do operation reform Francisco Gino
Barbara Jordan do you know who Barbara
Julie is absolutely yes she was a civil
rights leader african-american woman
thanks she gave she gave one of the most
important speeches on immigration she
did she addressed all these issues
family migration and her view on this
was our primary responsibility not at no
offense to immigrants we are a nation of
immigrants and we should welcome
immigrants to the United States when we
can fully assimilate them when when
they're merit-based not just family
based but merit-based immigration but
she said what's most important
especially with low-skilled workers that
they end up displacing necessarily
American workers especially African
Americans and Latinos in busy shoes have
so she was wrong she was wrong
absolutely she was not wrong before we
had an influx of illegal immigrants in
the United States who did these jobs
match net magicians that was before oh
my goodness that was because we created
a void a vacuum with the war on poverty
in the late 60s where we guaranteed in
this country minimum standard of living
but you know what we create a vacuum for
these little skill and high skill you
know why is it tires not easier why
shouldn't we in the United States
Francisco take the if it's the best and
the brightest coming to the United
States why should we take the best and
the brightest from other countries who
clearly need there were
and their help in their home countries
well we we sure went at Albert Einstein
didn't we miss Ingram we'll take it was
more variational base than merit-based
because he knew how to do it and we love
them so yes we're a nation of immigrants
come on guys let's do a migration from
don't be chicken Congress president
rethink what deportation do you favor
like what kind of deportation only like
violent criminals or should anyone else
from in ition let's come up with a
definition tell me what what the ticket
cost to live in this country pay you
bills pay your taxes support your family
don't commit crimes you get to stay
question for you
if someone immigrates into the united
states do you think a family sponsor
should be financially responsible for
them so the US taxpayer isn't absolute
absolutely yeah you would agree to that
enrollment on a Friday in awaken it we
have never collected we have never
collected a one single financial sponsor
not one was tough Shan Malik or whatever
her name is from the San Bernardino
remember her the San Bernardino absolute
life came in on a fraudulent was a
different type of thing was an
engagement visa but Latonia fraud had
enough totally fraud to taint
immigration we're gonna find out more
from mister side paav and how many
family members and other associates he
helped bring into the United States
we're going to confirm that 23 statistic
or get the right statistic but we
appreciate you joining us very much on
thank you so much